[موسيقى]
من وجهه نظري فان اغلب المشكلات المرتبطه
بانعدام الاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط نبيعه
من دوله واحده وللاسف هذه الدوله هي ايران
ايران لديها مجموعه من الوكلاء والشركاء
في المنطقه وتوفر لهم المساعدات الفتاكه
ويستغلون هذه الشبكه لبث الفوضى عبر منطقه
الشام والخليج العربي ولمهاجمه اغلب
الشركائنا في مجلس التعاون الخليجي
[موسيقى]
لا شك ان البرنامج النووي الايراني يسبب
القلق لكل من يعيش ويعمل في المنطقه
والمهام الموكله اليه هي ضمان الجهوزيه
وتوفير الخيارات المحتمله لردع الايرانيين
والاستجابه لاي تهديد النابع من حصولهم
على سلاح النووي وهذا الامر لا يقلق
امريكا واسرائيل فحسب بل يخلق كل دول
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
حيث ان الحصول على سلاح النووي سيكون
تاريخيا
بشكل اكبر ونحن نعمل بشكل اساسي عبر
القنوات الدبلوماسيه والطرق الاخرى في
محاوله لمنع الايرانيين من الحصول على مثل
هذا السلاح
[موسيقى]